well families can now experience the
magic
of the nutcracker up close now you know
the pandemic
has really stopped a lot of las vegas
productions put them on hold but
there's a brand new exhibit uh offering
a very rare behind the scenes
look of the nutcracker and hector mckee
is live inside the discovery children's
museum
with all the details this morning and
hector may i say you look
dashing in purple
thank you very much sherry not only am i
experiencing the magic of the nutcracker
i am
wearing it check this out this is a real
costume piece
worn here at the las vegas production
but as you just mentioned as many other
things canceled by the pandemic
the nutcracker production a holiday
tradition here in las vegas it's not
happening this year
and so we have all of these costume
pieces and it really looks like a
fashion show
look at this this is really neat you get
to be really really close to these
costume pieces joining us live
we have melissa who is a ceo here at the
discovery children's museum
good morning to you good morning hector
we are so happy to have you
and to be able to show these beautiful
costumes as you mentioned
this is snow scene so what you're seeing
is a
midway through the first act and our
real snow that falls here at the smith
center stage you have as a part of this
exhibit and that's truly magical
especially to get
this close to these pieces we have not
only costume
wardrobe we have real set props
absolutely to be this close and and
there is magic the nutcracker is all
about magic and we've translated that
here in a little behind-the-scenes look
tell us a little bit more about the
mission to bring this closer not only uh
for children but for entire families all
across the valley and giving them
something to do
for the holidays it's so much about the
holidays are cancelled this year that we
wanted to
really use this partnership as a way to
bring the holidays back into the lives
of our families here in las vegas
and we have the nutcracker off to the
side we also have
the rat queen we have a lot of things
including the uh
the dolls over here so this is battle
scene
um coming from party scene into battle
scene what you're looking at
up close and of course the real life
nutcracker
that grows out of our prop nutcracker
so you actually have to uh do a little
bit of magic to bring this to life
is that right that's right so what do
you do that's drosselmeyer's job
so you as uncle drosselmeyer you hold
and
you put your magic right into the
nutcracker to bring them to life
like this very good yes
all right so uh before we go let's go
over the details it all starts tomorrow
[Music]
we are open every day including mondays
during the holiday while
while schools are closed and is there an
additional cost to enjoy this
no there is not admission grants you
entry to
the special exhibit here all right thank
you very much for having us we'll be
back in half an hour to show you a
little bit more
for now reporting live hector mckia and
the nutcracker
back to you
oh thank you so much hector boy we sure
do miss the stage at the smith center i
know a lot of people
spend their holiday tradition going to
see the nutcracker at the smith center
so
a behind-the-scenes look is really a
rare treat we appreciate it